じゃあよろしくお願いします
四十一番 アチラン ワタヤン カヨ パタウィン アディセッサティ
チュッド アペータ ヴィンヤーノ ニラッタンワ カリンガラン
アチラン ワタヤン カヨ パタウィン アディセッサティ
これは一つよく日々観察する一つ
慈悲の-- 慈悲じゃなくて
無常の瞑想の一つなんですが
えーと アチランというのはあまり長持ちしないという意味で
チラっていうのはもう永遠長持ちするということで
アチラっていうのはそんなものではない
あまり長持ちしないっていうのは日持ちはできないということで
無常ということですね
ワタ 確かに というのは確かに長持ちはしない
アヤン このカヨ 体は この体は確実に
確実に長持ちはしないものである
パタウィン アディセッサティ
パタウィンというのはこの土のこと
大地のこと 土に戻ります
土に寝てしまう アディセッサティというのは寝るということを横たわるという意味であって
しかしこの場合は土に戻りますと
だいたい遺体は捨てる時は立てて捨てるということはないんです
横 横たわった形で捨てるんです
ですから その言葉使っちゃうと
父に横たわるということは
父に 土に戻ると だから意味は
この体は実に長持ちしないもので
土に戻るんですと チュッド
それは前の文章につなげなくちゃいけない形容詞なんですね
チュッドっていうのは捨てられて
アペータ ヴィンヤーノ
意識が消えたところで
抜けたところで 意識が抜けてしまうと
この体から捨てられます
体を それで上の二行につなげなくちゃいけない
で 実にこの体は長持ちはしない
意識が抜けて 抜けたところで捨てられて
土に戻るんだ 土に戻るんだという意味なんです
それで喩えがありまして
ニラッタンワ カリンガラン
焼けてしまったこの薪
死を背負った薪のようにと
喩え話は一番わかりやすいという推測で言ってるんですけど
それはもう現代社会は変わってますからね
なかなか一番喩えがわかりにくいということもあります
で あの 火はだいたい薪で引き起こすということはね
昔は普通でしたけどね
今は知らないんですけどね
で 薪っていうのは一応火を付けて終わっちゃうと
もう炭になっちゃって
もう役に立ちません また火をおこすためにも使えないし
炭にもならない 炭を使う場合は炭として薪を燃やさなくちゃいけないんですよ
ただ 薪を燃やしただけで炭になりました
これがまた役に立つということはないんです
ですから 死を背負う薪っていうのは何の役にも立たない
触るとぼこところもない
もうほとんど焼いてますからね
だから何の価値もない
それは注釈書では強引なエピソードみたいなものを書いてあって
薪を拾う人々は森に入って
適当に薪を拾って切ったりして
まっすぐなものとかね
では ひと束にしたりとかね
ただちょっとちょっと曲げたい
曲げてるものはそれなりにまた別に合わせたりして
束にして持っていく それでもう森の中で拾うものだからね
木の枝をね 枯れてる枝を切ったりして
それで あの 役に立たないものはね
例えばあの 筋というんですか
この あれ 何て言いますか
節でしたっね あの枝と枝がつながってるところとかね
それを三角形とか四角形とかなったりしてね
そこは使えないんですよ
もう例えば三本枝分かれてると
まあそれは枝三つを取って
真ん中のところはもう捨てちゃうんですね
これはもう束にしたってもめんどくさくても束にはならないし
だから役に立つ枝だけ切ってしまって
あの筋のところは捨てちゃうとかね
あるいは あの 燃えないものもありますね
木の中 枝の 薪の中でも
燃えないというか あまりにも軽くて
もうサーッと燃えてしまって
もう役に立たない もうちょっと硬くなければ
まあゆっくりゆっくり燃えてもらわなきゃ
まあ火の役目は果たさないんですね
ですから 枝は枝ですけど
薪にもならないものもあります
そこら辺では まあ皆様に経験ないんだからね
何の説明もできない まあおそらく木なんかもそれほど見たこともないと思いますけど
で そういうものはそのままもう捨てちゃうんですね
そこで まあ後から後から薪を拾いにお子さんたちが森に入っても
あれがもう落ちてるものは全然拾おうとはしない
役に立たない で どうなるのかというと
まあそのまんま土に戻るんです
捨てられたまんまで ですから
この何の役にも立たないという意味で
薪 あの 使用済みの薪にしているんです
だから捨てられた薪だったら拾ってもいいんだけど
この捨てられた薪といっても意味が違うんです
薪にならない で  これがお釈迦様はこの体について
あの 語れた文章で えーと
まあこれもまた世間の考え方とは正反対だと思いますけど
まあ世間では まあ体っていうのは大変尊いものとして
聖なるものとして肉体を見ているんですね
で 肉体しか何も考えてないんで
例えば人が死んじゃったらそれで終わりますよという場合でも
まあ肉体だけしか知らないと
で 仏教はそこですごい正反対の立場を取っていて
もう肉体のことをあなた方は心がなければ知らないでしょうと
心で知っているにも関わらず心を否定するんですね
だからみんな否定するんだからないという多数派の論理で世界は動いているんです
で 例えば自分に手があるということは
手に感覚がなければ知ることはできないし
痛いとかかゆいとかね
もう体がだるいとか いろんなこと言ってるのはこの感覚のことなんです
で 感覚が感覚を認識するんです
で 手を認識することはできないんです
私に手があるんではないかと
そんな認識できません
手という感覚があって
その感覚を認識する だから手を見えなくても手があるということは知っているんです
だから感覚を認識して我々は生きている
それでもう 手があると推測するんですよ
結局は この推測が我々は実際の経験
直接直視するものであると経験だと思ってますけどね
ちょっと違うんじゃないかなと仏教は言うんです
だから私がいるという場合でも
この心認識そのものについて私がと言ってますが
それは人間にはなかなか理解できない
私がいるんだから私がいるんじゃないかなというふうに大胆にもう喋るんです
それがすごい論理的だとも思ってるんです
仏教から見れば そういう論理でも何もないんですね
そういうところでは 結局私がいるといって
なんで私がいるとあなたは思いますかというと
あなたの認識でしょうと
認識があることはあるんですけど
瞬時に瞬時に瞬時に ずーっと変えて変えて変わって変わっていくものが認識であって
認識っていうのはちょっと一言で変わってしまうものですから
もう花火よりも早く変わるんですね
で あまりにも早く変わってしまう
だから瞬時に消えてしまうものは自分だと言えるのかということもありますしね
それはブッダの立場で
そんなことをいくら説明しても
あまり理解はできない状態になっているんです
そんなこと言っても私がいるというふうにすごいしっかりするんです
えーと  それで体があるということが
体の感覚があって その感覚を認識する
で 感覚もまたずっと変わらなきゃ成り立つものじゃないんです
で 感覚は変わるということを人間には簡単に経験できるものなんですよ
例えば 痛くなっていた手が後で痛くがなくなっちゃう
痛くも痒くもなかった手はまた痛みかゆみが戻ったりする
で 瞬時に瞬時に感覚が変わるんだから
我々は足を動かしたり
手を動かしたりしている
例えば 足を上げて運んで下ろすということは
感覚が変わらなきゃできるものじゃないんです
足を上げたところで上がっているという感覚を
上げたという感覚がなければ
ずーっと上げてるんですよ
でもそれはありえないんですよ
だから上げるという時はずっと上がっているという感覚があって
そこでまあここまでという感覚はね
ここからはこれ以上上がりませんという感覚が出てくるんです
それで上がるということはストップして運ぶということにするんですね
運ぶとしたっても もう運んでいる間はずっと感覚が変わっていって
ここ以上はもう運べないということはわかったところで
そこでストップになるんですね
それで下ろすということにするんです
だからこの感覚っていうのは
瞬間瞬間変化しないと成り立つものではありません
ずいぶん単純ですけど
何十年瞑想したってもそれが理解してくれないんです
私の指導が間違っていると
徹底的にもう攻撃はしないんだけど
もうもういわゆる心は全く度別な方向に変わって置いておくんです
それで私も全然そういう仏教的な信仰が伝わってこないんだから
まあいないものにするんです
存在しないものに でないとこちらが困るんです
肉体があるんだけど この肉体について何とかしなくちゃいけないと思っちゃうでしょうに
肉体しかないんだから
心は仏教的に傾いてないでしょう
だからもういないことにした方が私にとっては楽なんです
で 心を傾こうとしてくる人にだけ
しっかりとアドバイスはする
単純なことなんですけど
それはなかなか理解しないんです
で なんで足を上げた上げていたことはやってやめたのかと
なんで運んでいたことをやめたのかと
それはもう瞬間瞬間感覚が変わっていくんだからなんです
それで瞬間瞬間感覚が変わっていくと
認識も瞬間瞬間変わっていて
違う認識になるはずなんです
認識が私であるならば
瞬間瞬間私という実感というのは
すーっと絶えず変わっていくはずなんです
その中で本来の私っていうのは成り立たないとわかるはずなんです
ただの一時的な現象であると
それがわかれば もう瞬時に心集中するだけで
預流果の悟りの境地に至るんです
それができないんだからね
だからとことん攻撃してください
勝ちます  それで この俗世間の考え方というのは
体は尊いもので 体の面倒を見るべきであると
ちゃんと健康な食べ物を食べて
もう長い間体は調整してから修行したってもいいんじゃないかとかね
ある人が堂々と私に言うんですよ
健康な体に健康な魂が宿るんだから
なんであんたはその もうそういうヨーガやらもう指圧やらもうあれやこれやとかね
そんなものを馬鹿にしているんですかと
何を食ってもいいと言ってるんでしょうかと
それではもう成り立たないんだと
健康な清らかな食べ物を食べて
健康な清らかな環境で住んで
ある日本の行者が まあ日本で有名な人で
かなり尊敬されている人ですけど
あるところに行って まあここらは農薬使ってますから
やっぱりまあ年も経たない場合はもうこちらでは道場なんか作れませんとかね
いろんなところに道場とかあるんです
この人はいつ仏道に入るのかと
明らかに唯物論者で しかし自分がそれに気づいてないんです
徹底した仏教的な行者だと
言って まあいろんなところへ行って瞑想したりしますけども
かなり知識人はものすごい知識人です
ですから 物理的な知識はしっかりあるんだから
言ってることは嘘じゃないんです
で 土を見ると本人が専門家だからわかるんです
結構農薬使っていて もうもうもうもう何て言いますか
もう農作できない状態になっている
死んでいる土地であると
じゃあそこはもうもらいますから
いろんなところで その人は
でもここはもうこのままもう何十年も置いておかないと
こちらでは座禅組んではあかんとかね
何 何言うのかと私は言いたいんですけどね
で 肉体のことだからね
やっぱり誰と喋ってみたっても
やっぱり体はとても大事であると
って思ってるし 体よりも心
体が大事だというので
体がとても大事であると
心の存在すらも知らないんです
無視をするんです で あの
いまだに誰も理解しないのは
死んだら体捨てるんだっていうことをね
全くそれすごい難しいみたいです
理解するのは 死んだところで体がそのまま土に戻るとかね
なんかすごく難しいみたい
それってどういうことかとわかりませんだけどね
例えば人が埋葬したところで
もう何十年も経つと全部土に戻りますけど
まあいろいろ今いろんなこの土に戻らないようにいろんなことをやってますけどね
で まあ時々ミイラになったり化石になったりもするし
そんなものも結局は自然現象で
まあ化石になったら元のものじゃないんだからね
結局は この土がもう雨によって流れて流れて
この石になる物質はもうその中に入り込むんです
それで化石になるんであって
だから体永遠ということになるわけじゃないんです
で 化石になったら成分が違うんです
で とにかく 土になったら
まあただの土なんですけど
まあ世間ではそうは思わないんです
こちらにまだ生きているんだと
生きている時は人は全く無視して随分失礼にいろんなことやってます
その人が死んだとこ死んで
もうもう一応燃やしちゃって
それで燃え燃え骨が残るように
あのあれ 何て言いますか
熱を調整して燃やすんでしょ
もうちょっと火を上げればね
骨も灰になるんですけど
それで骨にすごく執着して
これがお母さんだと お父様お元気ですか？とかね
それには悪口言ってはいけないんです
すごい尊い高度な文化だからね
とにかく人間にわからないっていうことだけ言いたいんですね
この心っていう機能があるっていうことはね
で これがもう うん どれぐらい難しいかというと
例えば海で溺れて死にかけてる人が
水なんかどこにあるのかと
あるわけないんじゃないかと言って威張ってるような感じなんです
例えばちょっとあんた泳げばそこら辺にちょっと引っかかるものありますよと
そこでなんとか命拾いできますよと
何言うんだ 泳ごうと言ったって
水がなければ泳げんでしょうにと
どこにあるのかと 本人が本当は溺れかけていますけどね
それで溺れて死んじゃいますけど
死ぬ死ぬ瞬間でも認めない
水があると その場合 すごい知識人でしょ
そんな簡単に絶対認めないって態度っていうのはね
その全くその例えと同じなんです
我々は心できていて 心に支配されていて
もうもう心の奴隷になっていても
絶対心の存在を認めない
体の存在だけと で 心はほんのちょっとおかしくなっちゃうと
もうものすごい人生がダメになるし
で 食べたご飯 ちょっとお腹に口に合わなかったら
まあ 1 日ぐらい苦労するだけで
全部もう下してしまえば終わりでしょうに
しかし 心はちょっとねじったらどうなるのかと
人生そのものダメになっちゃうでしょうに
しかし認めないっていうところはね
すごいんです 心の存在だけは絶対認めない
まあそういうことだから
世界はそういう風に哲学
宗教ももう科学もなんだかんだもできてるんです
そういう前提で 心はなしと
あると言ったら では何グラム
何グラムですかとか そう言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
大きさはどれぐらいですかとか
結局物質で言わなくちゃいけないんです
物質の中でももう尺度っていうのは同じ尺度で何でも測れないと知ってるくせに
心になってくるとそういう理屈を出してくるんですよ
例えば電気を測ると 石を測ると
同じ測りで測れますかね
電気の物質で石の物質ですけど
しかしその測り方は違うでしょうに
ものによって それで石を計測する尺度で電気は計測できんだから電気は存在しない
あと秤に入れて重さが出てくるでしょうに
何キロとか 電気はそれ出てこないでしょうに
だから電気は存在しない
巻き尺とでも石だったらもう寸法は取れますけどね
では電気の寸法は取れないです
だから存在しないと という理屈を持ってくるんです
物理学者たちは 心があるんだったら
それはどれぐらい重いか
どれぐらい大きさあるか
どんな何の色でスペクトラムは何なのかとか
だからそんなのも心の中にいながら
認めないんですからね
ここで思考の展開っていうのは
仏教を理解するためならね
そういう思考の転換っていうのはすごく必要なんです
私 すごい単純なことだから説明しますよ
決して難しいことではないんです
それで このブッダの体に対する見方っていうのは
実際に体っていうのはもう壊れかけているものやと
もう持ちませんと 意識が抜けた時点で捨てるんだよと
捨てちゃうと土に戻ると
それぐらいのものやと
それもこれがもうわかっちゃうと
その瞬間にすごく体がショック受けちゃいますよと体と心が
執着なくなるんです 悟りを開くためには
このぐらいの芸でも十分なんです
私は昔々 初めてこの芸を聞いて
すぐショック受けちゃったんだから
感動したんです アチラングワタヤンカーヨって
初めてどちらかというと
私を出家していただいたこの大長老と一緒にこのお勤めをやっている時は
大長老すっごいお年上で
で まあこちらはゆっくりもう一緒に唱えるだけなんですけど
低い声で では 長老の声がじーっと耳に響いて入っちゃったんです
で なんとなく体がジッと
もう変わったというかね
変化したんですよ そういうふうにゆっくりゆっくり体に対する
もう執着っていうのはね
まあ理解していかなくちゃいけない
発す前にとにかく  それでそのままその場で覚えておいたんです
その偈を この  遺体見るチャンスはあればね
もうそこでわかりますけどね
なかなかこの社会で死ぬ人はいないんだから
なかなか遺体は見られませんね
で 遺体を見てみると もう何がないかと
この体にはね ないのはただ認識だけなんですね
認識がなくなったらどれほど変わるのかと
ただの物体になってしまうでしょう
それはわからない これこそ仏様やっていうことと拝みますからね
仏様になったと なんか死んじゃったらえらい
あのもう腐りかけてる遺体がね
本当は見ようともしないくせに
気持ち悪くて 仏様に仕立てるんです
誰一人死体は見ないんですね
みんな必死で 必死で拝む
それ拝むたびに悪 悪事やってますよ
だって無明 無明 邪見をとことん強化するんだからね
でも仏教では遺体っていうのは
このすごい あの心清らかになる
あの良い対象であると
で ものを見ると心が汚れたり清らかになったりする
この影響で 心が汚れるものっていうのは悪い
もう不幸な対象 見ない方がいい
聞かない方がいいと その中で人間に幸福をもたらす対象の一つは死体なんです
見ることできてもそれで幸福ですよと
で 世界の考え方は逆ですけどね
遺体が見るところがこちらにありましたと思っただけでも
もう気持ち悪くて別なところに逃げるんです
まあ人が自殺したんだから
だったらそのアパートも騙さないと借りないでしょうに
いいアパートがありますと言ったところで
まあ実はそこでも あの
もう先月人が自殺しましたけど
だったら結構ですと で
断る それで不動産屋はそんなこと言わないんだからね
自殺ではなくても 毎日幽霊が出ている家であろうとも全然言わない
すっごくいい物件だよと
なかなか手に入らない早く契約しないと
明日はわかりませんよと
そういうふうに言うんだから
まあ堂々と使ってますけどね
しかし 人が死んだベッドなんかだったら
それだったら絶対寝たくないでしょ
そんなもんですけどね
病院に行ったらね 聞く？このベッドで人が死んだことがあるのかと
だからバカな思考でいると
いつでもバカを見ているんです
で 仏教はものすごいバカにしてるんです
そういうことはね で あるエピソードが
エピソードいくつかありますよ
あるバラモンが 自分が死んだら
人は誰も埋葬したことがない
すごい清らかなところで埋葬してもらわなくちゃいけないんだと
えらいもう肉体主義者なんです
人類仏教以外はみんな肉体主義者ですからね
尊い魂宿ってる自分の体はね
こんな汚い他のカーストの人なんか埋葬したところで
埋葬したらもう汚れますからね
っていうことで 自分が死ぬ前に自分の足で場所を探すんです
なかなか人が入らない
もうという そういうところに
人が住まない 入らないようなところに行って言ったら
ものすごい寿命があるある木を一本見つけたんです
かなりもう古い木なんです
木は寿命ある もうもう二千年でも年取る場合もありますからね
自分の人々にその場所を示して
私が死んだらこの木を外して取って
そちらに埋葬しなさいと
場所を決めて いいところ見つけた
誰も埋葬していないとこ見つけたんだと
清らかな場所と そちらすっごい自慢げな顔してるんだから
お釈迦様がその人にもう聞くんです
なんてあんた随分満足そうな顔して
実際 お釈迦様よく聞いてくれたと
私はこういう考え方ですと
自分の肉体はね すごい清らかなところで埋葬してほしいんだから
場所を見つけてきたんだと
お釈迦様はね あのね あの
なんとか何とかところにある場所でしょうと
この人びっくりしたんです
なんで？なんでお釈迦様それ知ってるんですか？と聞いたら
だってお前はね もう百回以上その場所で埋葬してるんだよと
過去で 話ちゃったんです
お前死ぬたびにそちらに埋葬してくれと頼んで過去でね
お前わからないだけで
そこら辺でどれぐらい人が埋葬しているのかと
見つかりっこはないんだと
他の人埋葬していないところと
ものすごい厳しく説法したんですけどね
そのすごい強烈に厳しく言わないと
人間っていうのは思考は変えませんよ
人間の無知っていうのはかなりもうすごい強烈なものなんです
で そういうエピソードっていうのはいくつかあります
まあほとんど似てますけどね
似てるんですけど 言いたがっているのはやっぱり
肉体について何考えてる？そんなのはただの物体
捨てちゃえばいいんじゃないかというぐらいの話なんです
[背景音楽]もう一度
このすごく あの  お釈迦様の言葉だから
まあこれだけ素晴らしいということは言えませんだけど
もうどんな言葉でももう最高な
まあ極端な もうこの上ない言葉ですから
まあこの経典は一番優れてるっていうことはまあびっくり言えませんだけど
もう全て まあ金言というかね
で まあこれはいくらかもう
かん まあわかる人には
何の注釈なしにちらっとわかるんですね
だから注釈用の必要とするとちょっとめんどくさいんですけどね
これは注釈何もいらん
アチランワタヤンカーヨ
パーリ語を知っている人にとっては
もうそのまま理解できるんです
だって私も子供の頃 何のことなくもうわかってしまったんだから
まあそれですっげえ頭のいい時
パーリ語なんかもう全然知らなかったし
で ですからまあ簡単に理解できる
アチランワタヤンカーヨ
アチラン で アチランと最初に入れるんです
だから強調する単語 あの
前にアチランという言葉強調する
長持ちはしないと すぐ壊れるんだよと
あと確かにアヤンカーヨ
この言葉 それから次のアイデアが付け加えて付け加えていけばいいんです
すぐに大事なことはパタウィングアディセッサン
土に戻りますよと どんな時かというと
ちょっともう捨ててしまいますね
体が いつ捨てるかというと
アペータヴィンヤーナ
認識がなく出ていたら
まあ捨てる だから か ある物体に認識がある場合は
我々は生きていると言っていて
命だと言うんですよ 認識が出ていたら
もう生きているとは言わない
もう死んだと もう遺体ですと
って言うんです ニラッタンはカリンダラ
役に立たない この捨てられた薪のように
もう薪を捨てたら もう誰ももう捨てられる薪だったら誰も拾うことはしないんだからね
で 木材の場合は一番最後は薪でしょうにね
もうベッドは作れないわ
タンスは作れないわね
立派なものだったらそれでタンス作ったりベッド作ったりとかしますけど
まあ車を作ったり いろんなことに柱に使ったりとかね
もう柱にもならない もう何にもならないものはもう薪でしょうに
燃やすしか 燃やして火を作るしかないと
それにも役に立たないものは何
何に役に立つんですかね
もう捨てるしかないんです
そのように捨てられますと
一応その偈をできれば覚えておいてください
アチランワタヤンカーヨ
パタウィングアディセッサティー
チョッドアペータヴィンヤーナ
ニラッタンワカリンガラン
で まあこれ偈 この四十一番目は
あの 心の章に入っている偈なんです
なんでこの偈はもう これはもう死体というかね
瞑想ではないかと なんで心の章に入ったのかというと
ポイントがあるんです
我々はすごい体は私は捨てたっても
心が抜けた瞬間という
その一言葉で心の章に入れているんです
心が抜けたらもう終わり
だから いかに心っていうのは
中心的で大事な なのかということでもあります
だからこの編集者は このチャプターに分けたお坊様
阿羅漢たちは まあそのポイントを取って
あの 心の章に入れているんです
覚えておけと 肉体よりは大事なのは心だよということを言いたいと
言いたいために だから私の説法でもそこは徹底的にハイライトして喋ったんです
皆様何言うんでしょう
関係ないことをなんで喋るのかと思うかもしれませんだけど
それは関係ないことを喋っていたわけじゃなくて
この第一結集で編集した大阿羅漢たちが
まあどこら辺は考えて
このブッダの言葉でどんなポイントが大事なのかと考えて
そこはまあ心の章に入れたんです
で お釈迦様が住んでいた時は
この あまり名前を知られている人ではないんですけど
ある人が出家したんです
だいたい名前ティッサと言うんですけど
このティッサという名前というのは
名前を知らない場合はすぐつける
タロジロみたいな名前でごく一般的なんですね
英語で言えばジョーンとかスミスとか何とかいうような感じで
名前は全くも知らないままジョーンにしましょうというようなことで
ティッサということをつけちゃうんです
どうせ本名ではほとんどエピソードは出てこないんです
たくさんのエピソードは実際にあったことは記録ありますが
本名は変えるんです あだ名にするんです
本名でも知っている方々っていうのは数少ない
お釈迦様とサーリプッタモクレン尊者の場合でも
やっぱり本名は使ってないんです
でも記録はしている ちゃんとした人物で
家柄もあって 名前で知られたっても別に恥ということはないんです
そういう人々はもう一応あの人やとわかりますよ
アングリマーラ尊者とかね
アングリマーラはあだ名なんですけど
名前は消してます 名前はアリンサカなんです
しかし ちゃんと母親はこの名前で
父親はこの名前で それはまた王様の顧問で
なんとかコーサラ王様の顧問とか
そこら辺はしっかりしています
ですから アングリマーラがすごい人を殺してましたよと知られたっても
別に恥でも何でもない
それなりにすごい方になっているんだから
サーリプッタ尊者の名前はウパティッサで
モクレン尊者の名前はコーリと言うんですけど
誰も知らない と言っても
テーラワーダ仏教の人々は知ってますけど
お釈迦様にはゴータマとみんなに呼ばれてたでしょ
それは家の名前でね ファミリーネームなんで
ゴータマ・シッダッタですから
名前はね で そういうところで知られている方々
偉大なる人物だけなんですけど
他のお坊さんたちには
みんなにも一応あだ名つけちゃったら
もう誰の誰か分からなくなるんです
それはあえてそうするんです
一旦出家したら もうみんな同じであると
それである人が出家してティッサという名前になっちゃって
ティッサテーラという事で
これこの人が  出家してから
まあある時期からちょっと病気になったんですね
で どういう病気かと これ皮膚病なんですけど
小さな小さなこの 何といいますか
できものというかね あのもうというと
いというと ゴマ一粒くらいのなんか皮膚でちょっとできものね
そう イボでもないんですね
小さなものはできちゃうんですね
あっちこっち ん？で それで
まあどちらかというとなんとか今風に言えばね
なんかアレルギーみたいなね
アトピーみたいなものかもしれませんだけどね
で 皮膚がそうやって壊れていく
最初は別にまあそれぐらい
まあコマ コマじゃなくてゴマぐらいの大きさだからね
まあそんなにももう大胆に考えなくてもいいんですけど
まあこれがもう痒いし
で なかなか我慢できないしね
あっちこち出てきて で
これで これゆっくりどんどんどんどん大きくなっちゃうんですね
ゴマの大きさなんですけど
どんどん大きくなって大きくなるんです
大きくなって膿が溜まって
もう弾けたりする それで体中
どうすることもできない
だからまあ親戚はいないし
全く赤の他人でしょ 出家したっても
でも近寄れない もう体中もうもう傷だらけで膿
他のお坊さんたちももう別にあんまり面倒見なかったんですね
もう全く他人だから もういとも簡単に無視されちゃうというかね
まあ一応いろいろ治療とかお世話とか
初めはしたんだという話があるんですけど
注釈書こちらに書いてないんですけど
他のところであの戒律のテキストではね
で この出来事についてもっと役に立つ説明がありまして
お坊さんたちはもう追い出す
もう置いておいたみたいですね
面倒見ないんだと あなたの
なぜかというと 本人がすごいわがままで
ちょっとしたことで気が立ったりして
で お世話する人々を侮辱したり
怒ったり 怒鳴ったりする
で 治療 薬とかはまああの医者もいましたから
まあくれるんですけど
治療させてくれないわということで
何がこの そんな調子だったら私は帰るぞってことで
みんな別にもう義理がないんだから
じゃあそんな調子だったら私は面倒見ないと出て行っちゃう
他のお坊さんではかわいそうだから
では私はと行きますけど
またあの態度だから 離反された人の面倒見ようと言ったら
その人にまた怒鳴ったり蹴ったり侮辱したりしちゃうと
もうやりきれんということで
また出て行っちゃうということで
もう一人になってしまったと
だから性格がいわゆる患者としての性格が悪いということなんです
それで まあ戒律の本では
もう患者は患者なりに命がありますよと
病気やだからといって
もうあれこれでわがまま言っちゃうと
もう誰も面倒見ないんだよと
あんた方は親戚じゃないでしょうと
親子ではないでしょうと
あらゆる家から あらゆるカーストの人々は一箇所でいるんだからね
互いに慈しみなければもう成り立たんよと
だから一人の人がお湯でも沸かしてくれたら
これは感謝しなくちゃいけないんだと
だから まあ患者の 患者は守るべき決まりっていうのは
お釈迦様はまた教えてあるんです
いわゆるわがまま言わないこと
で 看病する人の話をよく聞くこと
その人を言う通りにちゃんと
はい分かりました はい
分かりましたと それから決められた薬をちゃんと飲んだり使ったりすること
それからいくら食べたくなっても自分に食べてはいけないと
決めているものはもう確実に食べないこと
あれ欲しい いくらなんでもなんとか持ってこいとかなんとか
それはできない で 食べなさいと言っているものは
いくら食べたくないとかね
まずいものは食いたくないとか
そういう我儘を言わないで
しっかりとそういうものは食べることとかね
それから 常に勘弁する人々に対して
ただ偉大なる慈しみを育てるとか
そういう患者の特色というか
患者の決まりですね とはあります
私は病気だからといって何でも許すっていうことは認めません
病気だから認めるところはありますよ
例えば 病気でみんな床に座って説法を聞いてるんですけど
病気で床には座れない
その場合はもうちょっと上のところに座ってもよろしい
それから杖持ったりするのは
もう体が弱くない場合はオシャレなんです
歩けない場合はオシャレではないんです
ですから 出家も杖を使ってはいいんだけど
それはもう足が弱くて歩けない時
道具として使う で 年のお坊さんたちでも何か杖を持ってると何か結構格好はいいんですけど
ミャンマーのお坊さんたち写真とか見てもありますけどね
すごい年でも杖つかまってる
結構ものすごい迫力ありますけど
やっぱりどこかでおしゃれにはなっちゃいますね
それは戒律違反じゃないんです
おしゃれじゃなくて そのお坊さんはもうそれは足が弱いし歩けないんだから杖を使っているだけなんです
それでも杖っていうのは
何か人間にとっては何か品格を与えてくれるんです
偉い人やっていう感じで
ですから もうギリギリの時でない限りは杖を使ってはいけないことになるでしょう
仏教では しかし 病気になったら
たとえ二十歳の人であろうとも
それは関係ないんです
杖を使ってもよろしいと
そういうふうに病気だからといって認めるものはいっぱいありますよ
それもすごい論理的に認めているんであって
性格っていうことじゃない
食べ物に対しても 元気な人々に設定している厳しい戒律は
そこでもうほとんど緩めてあげる
だから病気に合うようにいろんな食べ物を食べなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで病気が治るまではもう食べ物の戒律も一応解除してくれる
例えば自分が「私はこれ食べたいんだから作ってくれ」ということを頼んではいけないでしょうに
本当に病気になってもうそれこういうこういうものを食べなくちゃいけないということになったら
もう誰が それは言っても頼んでもいいということで
それでほんのちょっと
ほんのちょっと ほんのちょっとと何回
何回 何回とか食べるとかね
それもOKなんです しかし
どんな病気にもOKわけじゃないんです
そこら辺厳しい それはやっぱり胃が弱くて栄養が取れないとか
それで医者があなたはたくさん食べるなよと
ほんのちょっと ほんのちょっと
ほんのちょっと  四十回ぐらいに分けて
時間を開けて 一日の栄養を取りなさいよと
でなきゃ あなたはもう命はもう
もうわからないっていうことだったら
まあその人はそれで あるいはもう滑っちゃって足が怪我した
骨が折れたと その人は杖を使う
じゃあ私は病気だから
私もああいう風に食べましょうと言ったら
これはダメなんです 別に骨が折れただけで胃袋は大丈夫ですからね
それだったら他の部員と同じく決まりでやらなくちゃいけない
ですから この病気に合わせて
戒律はもう解除するなりに緩めるなりにいろいろありますけど
だから言って患者さんとして
患者としての戒律もまたあるんです
それは今前説明したところものなんですけど
それを守らないと知ったものじゃないんだよと
ということは 薬あっても看護なければ治らないという考え方の仏教は
変かもしれませんだけど
薬があっても一番病気治るための原因というのは
もう八割ぐらいは看護なんです
だから医者の治療よりは
仏教は看護の方が優先するんです
わかりやすく言えば 医者よりは看護師の方が位が上なんです
で 薬なくても看護で治りますからね
薬と医者がいても 看護がなかったらもう治らないんです
それで看護する人にはまた戒律がありまして
もう誰でも看護しなさいということではなくて
やっぱり看護したければ
その戒律をちゃんと勉強して
あの患者さんのもう一つ戒律二つ忘れちゃったんですよ
自分の症状をね 正直に素直に看護する人に言う
医者に言うことと看護に
看護する人に言うことは違うんですね
医者っていうのは全ての症状は気にすることはしないでしょう
医者は専門家だから 病気の診断すればそれでもう終わっちゃうんです
あらゆる症状については全然気にしない
そんなのは病気治したら全部治りますよという態度を取るんですね
例えば心臓が病気の場合
医者は心臓のこととその関連のことしか気にしない
その人が例えば足は随分痒いと
あるいは足はなんとなく焼いているような気がするんだと
それは別に医者はもう気にしない
看護する人に言わなくちゃいけない
するとその人はではちょっと冷やしてあげましょうとかね
ちょっと油でも塗りましょうとかね
そこまで気をつけるんですね
だから看護する人には症状っていうのは全て言わなくちゃいけない
それから薬 治療によってこの経過
それも看護する人に報告しなくちゃいけない
病気がどんどん症状が悪化するならばそれは言うし
あるいは減っていくならば
それもちゃんと今これぐらい楽になったとかね
それそれ言わなくちゃいけない
っていう二つも入ってます
それに合わせて看護する人の項目もありますね
で まず忍耐 患者が病気のせいでね
何言うかわからない そういうことを何言ったっても
もう気にしない 病気だから無茶苦茶なことを言ってるんだと
それは一つの病気の症状の一つであると理解する
これいわゆるすごい忍耐
それから看護するときは
もう清らかな慈しみで
この人は早くも治ってほしいという憐れみですね
カルマでやらなくちゃいけない
早くも苦しみをなくなってほしいという憐れみの瞑想というか
その感情を決して忘れてはならんと
自分が落ち込んだり もうやりくりがなくなっちゃうと
すぐ憐れみの瞑想 カルマの瞑想でまた気持ちを奮い立たせなくちゃいけないと
それから病気のことはよく知っておく
知識ですね これはこういうこういう病気であると
この病気 それからこの病気には良くない食べ物と食べ物
病気を早く治す 治る場合はどういう食べ物かとか
それは知っておくこと
次に専門家が治療する薬とか決めたりするんだから
その薬はどのように使用するのかとかね
それはよく理解しておくこと
そこでこの過程をちゃんと医者なんかにもちゃんとこういう風になってるんだから
こうしたらどうでしょうかとか
人にも方法をするということですね
そういうふうに看護する人の決まり
戒律の本には入ってます
で これがもっと前 こういう戒律なんかで設定する前の話
戒律はずっとお釈迦様が涅槃に入るまではもう完成完成してなかったんだから
もういわゆる出来上がったり
変えたり 編集したり いろいろまあまあその時代でしたから
お釈迦様のような現れたからはカチンと
これで終わりと クローズしちゃったんだからね
だからいろいろなところでエピソードが出てくる
この長老がなかなか性格が悪かったみたいですね
みんな逃げちゃったんです
誰も看病しないで しかし
これが何か特別な病気で
この場合は大体この業から出てくる病気だから
病名と病名でしたっけとか
なんとかはもうない 病名とかなんとかあったら
インドで当時での治療っていうのはすごい優れていたものがあったんです
何のことなく治しちゃったんです
しかし 業によって いわゆる今風に言えば業はわからないんだからね
認めないでしょうしね
遺伝的な 何的でしたっけ
先天的な  先天的な病 の場合はもうどうすることもできないでしょうしね
今もあの病名はありますけど
全く治療法はない病気もありますね
今も あの例えば筋肉がもう機能
筋ジストロフィーとかなんとかとかALSとかなんとか言いますけどね
そういう病気とかあります
どうすればいいかわからない
どんどん筋肉がもう収縮しちゃって
機能しなくなっちゃって
死んでいっちゃうんですね
それで足から始めて どんどん上に行って
人が死んでしまう それでも途中でストップする時もありますよ
なんか有名なね まあ天才みたいなノベル賞を取った人々も何人かいたんだからね
まあ病気にかかっちゃって
頭だけ機能するんですけど
体がストップするというね
あの有名なあの先生もそうでしょう
天文学者のホーキングスとかね
で 一応途中で止めたんですね
もうギリギリまで進んじゃって
指二本しか動かなくない状態になっても死ぬでしょ
死ぬんですよと思っても
まあそこら辺でまあ病気がまあストップしちゃったんです
まあそういうすごい大きな大型の人間だから
やっぱり精神的に負けないんですね
肉体は勝手にやれと だからそこら辺で結構心で勝っちゃうんですね
それは病気は治りませんよ
先天的というか 業だからね
でも病気はまあもうどこかで進んで進んで
どこかでも引っかかっちゃって
命まで取ることはできなくなっちゃうんです
本当は命まで取るはずなんですけど
そこは取れなくなっちゃう
命は心だけの世界だから
心で負けない場合は それは取れなくなっちゃうんです
それでも体って必ず壊れますから
必ず死んなくちゃいけないんですけどね
それでまあ このお坊さんの場合でも
これは先天的というか
この業ですね ですから
この小さな出来物が出てきて
大きくなって これがもう化膿してはじけてしまう
それでどんどん皮膚 最初は皮膚が壊れちゃうでしょうに
皮膚の次にどんどん中に中に入っていっちゃうんです
それでもいても立ってもいられるはずがないでしょうに
だから もしかすると このお坊さんがただ気が荒っぽいんじゃなくて
もう体中できものが出てはじけて痛くて
もう座れないわ 横になっていられないわ状態だから
ものすごいもうその嫌味で
もうあれこれやとか もうもう何を見ても嫌になってくるとかね
この薬塗りましょうっていったっても
もう指が触れただけでもものすごく痛いんだからね
誰かだから腹が立って怒鳴ったりした可能性もある
だからまあしょうがないと言えばしょうがないんですけど
やっぱり でも仏教の世界では
それはもういくらあなたに痛くても
指が人の指が触れただけでも痛いと言っても
それはしょうがないでしょうと
我慢しろっていうのは仏教の立場なんですね
それは患者さんの決まりやと
一人で泣いてわめてもいいんだけど
人に当たってはいけないんです
そこでこのお坊さんはまあもうすぐすぐ病気が悪化しましたから
これでみんなに見放されちゃうと
もう歩けないし 立てないし
ベッドに寝たまんまで
それから全部もう衣はもう膿だらけで
そこまた硬くなっちゃうでしょうし
外したりすることもできない
で そのままもう大便小便したりして
托鉢にも行けないでしょうに
まあ死ぬしかないんですね
そこでベッドになって寝たきりになった時点でもう終わりってことになっちゃうんです
もう それで もう最上ですから
お釈迦様がこれお釈迦様の知恵に入ったんですね
一人が死にかけているんだと
それでお釈迦様が ああ
やっぱりこの人は大変だ
病気を治してあげなくちゃいけないんだっていう態度でお釈迦様が慈悲を持ったわけじゃないんです
この比丘が悟られるんだと
そこら辺はもう真面目なんです
心は もうせっかく出家してるんだから
悟りを目指して その徳を積んで
それで出家したんですね
悟られるんだから死なすわけにはいきませんというぐらいのこと
だからもうブッダの慈悲でも偉大なる慈悲なんですけど
もう片っ端からみんなにこれ来るっていうことはないんです
自分たちも自分たちで清らかな心持ちたいという気持ちがなければ
ブッダの慈悲の力を全然感じないんです
世の中でいくらでも人が死んでいるでしょうに
しかし やっぱり 1 日でもなんとか頑張りたい
なんとか徳を積みたい
なんとかいいことをしたいという仏法に帰依して依存して
この通りに自分の力ある限りは頑張りたいという気持ちある人々は災難に遭わないんです
災難が起きても その時はブッダの力がきちんと働く
そういう人が 1 日生きていたら 1 日いいことをするんだから
その人のためになるんです
その個人のためになるんです
他の人は 1 日生活しちゃうと 1 日罪を犯すんだから
もうどうったことはないと
そちらにはブッダの慈悲が機能しない
たとえ慚愧したんだからと形式的にもう何かゴキブリを触るような感じで死んだゴキブリのように
それでは慚愧は心に入りませんよ
慚愧というのは並大抵のパワーじゃ力じゃないんです
人は必ず救うんです それは入っちゃうと
いつ悟るかというのは人の努力次第ですけど
一旦心に慚愧すいちゃったらね
もう必ずどんどんどんどん成長してうまくいきます
で 火口の王が参り込んで何かなっても
その人々はこれを見事に修行に使うんです
だから病気な人は探してはお釈迦様行って見んと見る
探しては見るとか それはまるっきりないんです
目の前にいる人でも綺麗さっぱり無視するんです
心が悪ければ 話もしない
時々大勢の人々集めたところで
前にいっぱい人が住んでいる
誰の顔も見ないで ものすごい「君どこから来たんですか」とやっても聞くんです
で それでこのテッサ長老のことをお釈迦様の心に入って
お釈迦様はこの比丘をね
同業者たちに捨てられているんだと
ですからもう誰も頼りにならないんだから
この時点で私は助けてあげなくちゃいけないということで
お釈迦様はこのお坊さんたちはなんか
あの もう結構清潔にいるんです
不浄観瞑想はするんですけど
かなり体を清潔にしておくんです
で だからすごい品格ある組織でしたからね
時々こう 拾った布とか布とかね
布切れとかね それはつなげてつなげて着てるんですけど
だから入れてボロ服着ていてかっこ悪い
気持ち悪いということにはならないんです
これはもうものすごくきれいに染めて
しっかりと抜いて ちゃんと洗って着ているんです
そこでほんのちょっとでも心も破れたら着てはいけないことに
お釈迦様はしているんです
ちょっとでも破れたらすぐそこを抜いて抜いてくださいと
時々虫に食べられたりして穴が開いちゃうと
もう小さな穴も大きさ書いてますけど
小さな穴でもあったらもうそれすぐ
直さなくちゃいけないんだと
あるいはパッチをして直さなくちゃいけない
そこでパッチをして して
して してなってくると捨てなさいよと
パッチばっかしのものけど
まだちょっと見た目が悪いんですね
パッチしなさいとも言ってますけど
もうパッチもあんまりにもここまでくると
もういい加減やめて捨てて別な衣
だからそれは決しておしゃれとかなんとかではなくて
その場合でお釈迦さんすごいことを我々に教えてるんです
すごく綺麗で清潔で品格よくいるんですが
欲がないし おしゃれではもう絶対禁止というね
正しい道っていうのは
仏教の中にはしっかりあるんです
例えば神父さんのね 服なんかはものすごいおしゃれなんですね
行事なんかやってるとか
何回着替えたりまでするんですね
これドラマじゃないんだからね
あまり見たことないんで
テレビとテレビではね
もう堂々と放映しているんだからね
すごいことやって放映してるんですけど
これ私が見るんだからね
もう余計な悪口言いたくなっちゃいますけどね
クリスマスなんかなってくると
もう日本のテレビでも生放送でね
バチカンのメサを放映するでしょうね
だから政教分離の世界だから仏教は禁止だけの話で
それは堂々と放映するしね
あの人 あのジジイがね
もうあれ入れ替える あれ入れ替える
ものすごい豪華って言っても何千万もかかる服なんですけどね
冠を入れ替えたり入れ替えたりと
今はすごいお年で病気でね
弱いんですけどね 前はかなり男前でしたからね
これ結構インパクト強く映りますよ
今はあんまり悪口言うのはね
とんでもないし 失礼ですけどね
だからそういう風に人の感動
人の感動を引き起こそうというのはものすごいやっちゃいけない
もう邪道ですね 仏教から見れば
あらゆる道具やらね 宝石いっぱいつけてる服を着たりして
それはもう邪道で 人間の弱みを握ってるだけ
仏教はすごく清潔でいる
で しかしちゃんと不浄観を覚えておくというところで
それで言いたかったのは
このだからこのあの寒かったんですね
昔はお寺に で よく体洗うぐらいはもうどっかのこの川に行っても体洗えますけど
で 寺の中でこの火を立てて
それからあれ 何でも蒸気って言うんですか
あの うん 蒸気を出して
もう暗い部屋なんですけど
その中にお坊さんたちはじっと座っているんです
言って体からもうとことん汗を出して
で 体綺麗にする で その時は何か泥を体に塗るみたい
昔はね 石鹸はなかったんですからね
それで川とかいるところに特別な何か泥があるんです
すっごいスムースで 気持ちはいいんですけどね
それはもう全部塗って
で 泥っていうのはこのすごい体にいいんですよ
どんな泥でもないんですけどね
あれはもう隙間だらけですからね
ずっと このパックみたいにしたっても皮膚に悪くはないんです
で そういうものを体中塗って
じっともう汗を流して
それからもう体洗ってしまうという
だからそこまで清潔なんです
それで これで元気で俺がいい男でいるぞと
これは禁止 だからこの今のインド人なんか見ると
ものすごいもう清潔じゃないでしょうに
寒いし 暖房はないし もうそれで体は縮めて縮めて
いろんないっぱいいろんな服を着て
汚いという 汚いというか
この健康的で清潔じゃないんですね
それは健康には悪い 寒いんだから細菌はいきなりもう発生しないかもしれませんだけど
それでも体の中あったかいんだからね
だからそうはならなかったんですね
仏弟子たちは もう顔を洗わなくちゃいけないし
歯を磨かなくちゃいけないわ
寒いとかなんとかとか
だからいいっていうことは全然ない
だからそこでもうサウナを張って
サウナってのはそんなにお金かかるものじゃない
もうちょっと窓がない
ちょっとしたもう泥で建物作ってね
その中で火をたてちゃえばね
煙だけ逃げてるようにしてね
で お釈迦様は何したんですかというと
もう出かけて そのサウナとかあるところに行って
自分で水をくんで釜をお湯を沸かしちゃったんです
誰にも言わない で だから悟る人なら
お釈迦様はどこまでなさるのかっていうことなんですよ
このサウナのところに行って
そこまでもう火を入れちゃったと思いますけど
それでもうちゃんと水をくんで釜を入れて
火をつけて お湯を沸かしちゃったと
で 適当にお湯が 水があったかくなったら
お釈迦様があのお坊さんがいるところに行って
ベッドのまま その人を一人で運ぼうとしているんです
で そうすると アナンダ尊者ら他の御分たちがさっさと来て
協力して 一応サウナのところまで運んだんです
お釈迦様はやっぱりそれでもベッドの頭のところ自分で取っていたんです
しゃくりましょうと 言って
そのもう服は脱がしたりすることは何もできない
もうものすごい臭かったんです
あまりにも臭くて もう当たり前ですからね
悪臭っていうのはもう耐えらないほど
そのままお釈迦様が今度お釈迦様が体にお湯をかけてかけてかけて
ベッドにいたまんまで
全部あの汚れを落として
それからもう衣をね 脱がしてもらって
全部 きちっと洗って干しちゃったんです
干してまた綺麗なところに寝てもらって
綺麗に洗った衣また着替えてあげて
それでその瞬間であのお坊さんの心がすごく変わるでしょう
そこでお釈迦様が何を言ったんでしょうかというとね
もう説法だけしたんです
で やっぱり気分が悪ければ説法を聞けないんですよ
だからお釈迦様ゆっくりとお世話したところによって
あの人の気持ちが申し訳ないという気持ちもあるでしょうしね
で それは気にすることはないんだと
体っていうのはそういうものであると
まったくもこんなもんで嫌なものであるというところで説法して
それで完全に悟り開くんです
執着がなくなって それでお坊さんも亡くなりましたけど
阿羅漢に もうそれはもう最後の一日なんです
どうせその日でもう亡くなるんです
で 亡くなる前にとにかく完全に悟りを開いてもらうなんかじゃ困ると
という困ることはないんですけど
もうそういう覚悟で出家した人だから
それは見放しはしない
お釈迦様のお世話で 彼がものすごく痛みがなくなって
随分いい気分になりました
だからもうもう 大便小便まみれたままで
体もものすごく壊れて食われて痛いままで
もうもう死にかけてたんだからね
お釈迦様はご自分の手でゆっくりゆっくりお湯をかけてかけてかけてあげて
綺麗に洗ってあげて それからゆっくり優しい心で衣を脱がせてあげて
その時はもう何も言えないし
で またそれまた全部衣を綺麗に洗ったんです
洗って干して で また着替えてあげて
的にもちょっとほんのちょっとだけ気持ちが良くなったんです
それで執着を捨てなさいよと
実際に問答するという
お経で阿羅漢になるんです
その出来事について お釈迦様がその時説かれたかどうかはわかりませんだけど
に対する偈なんですね
この体は全くも役に立たない
もう薪のように捨てられるものであると
それで亡くなったらお坊さんたちがね
ティッサ長老が亡くなったんですけど
どうなったのかと まあ彼がもう仏道を完成して阿羅漢になって涅槃に入られたんだとみんなに言うんです
お坊さんたちも不思議になるんですね
もう修行でき 修行してないんだからね
もうすぐ病気になってしまったんだから
でも お釈迦様のほんのちょっとの時間の説法を聞いて
もう完全たる悟り開いてるんだと
ちょっともう大物でしょうね
知恵はもう完成 ほぼ完成して生まれているでしょうに
そんなに偉大なる方なんですけど
なんであんな風になったのかと
肉体も全て壊れちゃって
骨までこの病気が発生して
ああいう風なものになったんです
それはもう誰がやったことでもありませんと
本人の行為の結果ですと
だから 何でも誰のせいでもなく
自分の心のせいやっていうのは仏教の決まりですからね
で その人の心の結果であると
その人はこの過去世でカッサパブッダがいた時代で
この人はこの漁 漁師じゃなくて
漁師ってお魚ですね 狩り
狩人 行っても鳥を捕るんですね
で 職業として森に入って鳥を捕まえる
鳥を網にかけて捕っちゃいますから
結構捕まっちゃうんですね
捕まって売ったりする
で 全部は売れないんだから
残りはどうしようかといったら
これ殺しておくと肉は腐るんだと
鳥だから逃げるとまた困るということで
足を折ったり 羽を壊したり折ったりして置いておくんです
で 逃げない まあただ まあもうただそのまま売るんだから
それで鳥を捕まってもう足を折ったり
足を折ったり カチャカチャカチャカチャ何のことなく骨を羽をね
潰したりして そのままボンボンボンと置いておく
だから鳥たちは次の日
次の日売っちゃえばいいということで
逃げることはできない
そういうことをしていたんだと
そこで当時でまたこの本人がものすごい悪いことを殺生して生活していたんですけど
ある日ある阿羅漢ですね
托鉢に行く場合はもう順番で行かなくちゃいけないんだから
その人の家の前にも立ちましたと
立ったところで 自分とは縁のない世界でしょうしね
私と全く縁のない世界のこの修行者が自分の家の前で玄関の前立ってるんだと
私はもう殺生ばっかりして悪いことばっかりして生活しているんで
全然悪人だと それでもこの聖者が来て待ってるんだからね
そのチャンス逃しちゃいけないということで
自分の家では一杯に具とか何でもありますからね
もうすごくごちそうを奢って
で 差し上げたんですね
そこで このお坊様と同じく私にも
あの この 何て言いますか
生きるべき時を達することができればということで誓願もする
阿羅漢はまあ  そうなりますようにと祝賀をしてもう帰ったそうで
そういう徳を積んだんですね
一応 とにかくその罪がね
カッサパブッダから ただ結果として体が壊れたということではないんです
これすごい罪を犯してますから
それでもう死んで天国に行くわけじゃないでしょうに
カッサパブッダとお釈迦様の間っていうのは
もう想像を絶する時間感覚あるでしょうに
その間でかなり苦労していたんです
しかし 徳も積んでいたんだから
またブッダの時代でまた人間に生まれて出家する気持ちになりまして
悟るところも一応完成しているんですね
しかし そこであのほんのちょっとの残りで
あれぐらいになりましたと
あれは業はまんまる受けたわけじゃなくて
業はほとんど苦労して地獄に落ちて苦労して苦労してきたんですけど
もうその悪業ももうほとんど終わってます
もうどちらかというと弁当は食べたんですけど
もうこれから捨てようとする弁当箱にも何か食べ物を残ってるでしょ
食べる ただ もう 何て言いますか
あの いろいろ汁とか何とかとかね
ちょっと残ってるでしょうに
品物は何もないんです
全部食べちゃって そういう
そんなぐらいの残りでこれぐらいになりましたと
だからその人の命がやっぱりその業によって断たれてしまっちゃったんです
そのお坊さんのね しかし
それは体のことで 心はちゃんと悟りを開くことはできましたし
その出来事の後でお釈迦様は比丘たちにね
あの 比丘が病気になったら必ず看病しなさいと
という決まりもまた定めておいたんです
忘れてはならんと いう場合は
もう比丘たちは必死で看病するんだけど
これまたトラブルばっかしでうまくいかないというところでお釈迦様はどんどんどんどん次から次へ次から次へと
あの 戒律を設定してあげたんです
そこで「ヨーマンウパッダヒヤ ソ ジラーナウパッダヒヤ」ってお釈迦様の言葉がありまして
誰かが私の面倒 お釈迦様のね
直々面倒見る人 面倒見たいと思う人がいるならば
病人の看病しなさいと
だから病人の看病することは
シャカムニブッダに直々面倒見ることであると
それぐらい それ以上は語れませんだからね
どれほど人が病気になると
看病することっていうのはありがたいことであるということになっちゃうんです
[紙の音]